hello we're now going to do some more
slope and then maybe some y-intercept
problems as well let's get started so
let me make up a problem let's say we
have the points 2 comma 5 the other
point let's make that negative 3 comma
negative 3 well first let's just graph
those two points I'm going to graph them
in yellow so 2 comma 5 let's see that's
1 2 1 2 3 4 5 so 2 comma 5 is going to
be right over there let me it's 2 comma
5 ok and then let me graph negative 3
comma negative 3 6 1 2 3 1 2 so negative
3 comma negative 3 is right over there
and then now let me draw a line that
will connect them
my new technique guitar in two pieces
I think that's good enough okay so let's
see if we can at least first figure out
the slope of the line then if we have
time we'll try to figure out the
y-intercept and then we'll know the
whole equation for the line let me pick
a slightly thinner color and we will get
started so the slope if you if you see
if you saw the last module that just
introduces how we calculate the slope
that's just rise over run or change in Y
whoops I'm still using the line tool
change in Y over change in X this is a Y
change in Y over change in X so let's
just do that real fast so let's take
this is our starting point so change in
Y could be five remember Y is the second
coordinate five minus negative three and
that's this one over now you do the
change in X to minus this is also
negative three well five minus negative
three that's 5 plus plus three so that
equals eight and then two minus negative
three once again it's two plus plus
three so that equals five so we figured
out the slope of this equation it's
eight over five and let's see make if
that makes sense let's figure out what
the rise and the run is if we were to
start at this point right here let's see
how much we have to rise to get to the
same y-coordinate as the other point so
let's see we're here and the other point
is up here so let's see how much we have
to let's see what let's figure out what
this distance is now's a good time to
use of fat
and I have a shaky end okay let's figure
out what that distance is that distance
is Delta Y which is change in Y so it's
one two three four five six seven eight
that equals eight and that makes sense
because if you think about what did we
just do
we just took y equals five which was up
here minus y equals negative three and
so we obviously we just calculated that
distance just by looking at the two
chord it's five minus negative three
when you do this calculation it actually
gives you this distance right here so
that's how we figure out how much we
have to rise so now let's do the run
well the run to go from this point to
the other point we went this far we went
that far and let's count how far that is
well it's one two three four five units
so we can say Delta X is equal to five
that's exactly the Delta Y over Delta X
is equal to 8 over five or rise over run
is equal to 8 over five and it would've
been the same thing if we calculated run
here if we calculated rise here it's the
same thing hope that's making sense to
you
I hope that also makes sense that if you
if the rise for a given run becomes more
than the then the slope of the line is
going to become steeper it'll become a
bigger number so let's see what we have
so far for the equation of this line so
so far we know the equation of this line
is equal to Y is equal to the slope
eight over 5x plus B so we're almost
done we just got to figure out I'm sorry
I'm using improper English we just have
to figure out this this B right here
well that'd be just so you remember
that's the y-intercept and that's where
we intersect the y-axis and since this
graph was is pretty neat we can actually
inspect it and see that well it looks
like we're intersecting the y axis at 2
so my guess is we're going to come up
with B equals 2 but let's solve it just
in case we didn't have this neatly drawn
graph here so how can we solve for B
well we can substitute values that we
know that work for X and
well either of these points are on that
line so we can substitute them in for x
and y so let's use the first one since
we're okay
so the y we get 5 will equal 8 over 5
times X well X there is 2 times 2 plus B
well now we just get 5 is equal to that
is a 16 over 5 plus B and then we get B
equals well 5 is 25 over 5 right 5 is 25
over 5 minus 16 over 5 equals 9/5 oh I
see so I was actually wrong when I
looked at when I looked at this graph I
said oh that looks like almost 2 so yeah
it's probably going to be probably going
to be 2 but when we actually did it
using algebra did when we did
analytically we actually solved that B
is equal to 9/5 so it all it's almost to
9/5 is 1 and 4/5 or 1.8 so that's almost
2 but it actually turns out that it's
not it's at 1.8 I can write it down as a
decimal 1.8 so the final equation for
the line I'm going to try to squeeze it
in at the bottom of this page it's going
to be Y is equal to well we know the
slope 8 over 5 X now we just add the
y-intercept plus 9 over 5 there we
solved it let's do another one and so
that's 9 or 5 I don't to be too
repetitive assault was to another
problem tend to do another problem and
let me put that graph back there again
graph
there you go all right I'm going to
think of two random numbers again if I
do this fastest YouTube puts a 10-minute
limit on me so let's say I had the point
two comma negative three and I had the
point negative 4 comma 5 so 2 comma
negative 3 let's plot that sucker real
fast so X is 2 so it's here and the
negative 3 1 2 3 so 2 comma negative 3
is there and negative 4 comma 5 so it's
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5 I have to count like
this because this graph is unlabeled but
if we actually were to draw in the
coordinates you would see that this is 5
and this is negative 4 and so on and
this is 2 and this is negative 3 and now
let's just draw a line
right there with my shaky hand okay
there you go
good line and another good line all
right so first we need to figure out the
slope well we could just do that doing
the algebra so slope is just Delta I'm
still using the line tool again Delta Y
over Delta X change in Y over change in
X let's take this Y is the first point
now so we'll say five minus this Y
negative three over now we have to since
we use the five first 50 so negative
four first as well negative four minus
two well 5 minus negative 3 that equals
8 and 4 negative 4 minus 2 or that
equals negative 6 and negative 8 over 6
well that equals if they wrote divisible
by 2 so that equals minus 4 over 3 and
let's see does that make sense as a
slope well if we were to go down 4 from
this point so if the rise was negative 4
1 2 3 4 so if we go down whoops I'm
using white that's why you can't see it
we go down by four here and then we go
to the right three positive three we
still end up on the line so it works
looks good to me let's see if we can
figure if I can solve the y-intercept in
30 seconds otherwise I'll started on the
next module so we get Y is equal to
minus four over three X plus B and
actually what we'll do is we'll leave
off here and I'm going to solve for B
and you can try to do it on your own
in the next installment of this
presentation